[Music]
today's question comes from taylor in
maryland taylor writes i'm married to a
serious spin thrift
i started using every dollar when he was
incarcerated three years ago well go
ahead and underline that one
and with my single income i was able to
tithe pay all our bills on time fund car
and home repairs and pay off 40 000 in
student loan debt with 65 000 left to go
can i just stop there
incredible taylor way to go
in our phone conversations he makes big
future money plans that i think are
unwise
if we benefit from the navient
settlement where the debt is canceled
and refunds are paid out the timing of
the payout would be just after he'll
return home
how do i deal with the stress of trying
to keep any refund from being wasted
he's seen the success from following the
plan and his response is basically
that's great i'm proud of you but we're
not following that plan when i get home
there's a lot of yikes going on in this
situation john but man taylor's
incredible taylor just solo her out i'm
like man she's crushing it it's it's
it's it does my heart good when we can
just stop and stop the the party here
for a second and just call somebody out
and say what an incredible human being
while your husband was in jail for a
couple of three years
you managed to take control back in your
home and i guarantee you took control
back in your heart and your mind your
spirit and you started just saying how
can i move forward and instead of
curling up you went after man this is
incredible
this it's an inspiring person yeah um
so he george here's a
a problem i i see that haunts all of us
okay not just taylor haunts all of us
and all um i'll use this as an example
when my son was born
he was a day old
and we brought him or two day three days
old we brought him home from the
hospital
i could see the chaos that erupted into
our home i didn't know we had to change
diaper i knew it changed diapers i
didn't know it was ten times a day and i
didn't know this and all that and
suddenly this clock started ticking in
my head which was when things get back
to normal
when
when things are just going to get back
to the way they were when me and my wife
could just go on dates whenever we
wanted to we could spend money like
idiots we could do whatever we wanted to
do
when they just gets back to normal right
and
whether it's having a new baby whether
it's dating and then getting married
whether it's getting a new job moving to
new town or whether it's your husband's
coming home from three years
it's so easy to just
default to well when things get back to
the way they were
and unfortunately and fortunately there
is no going back right things are
different now and so i love love this
analogy
that you could not go to manhattan and
get all of the glass and steel and smoke
and dust and sweep it all up and rebuild
the twin towers you can't do that you we
had to go in with architects and
construction firms and demo teams and
excavate the whole site get some
professionals around us and say what's
this new building going to look like
and we get to redesign it it gets to be
strong it gets to be arguably beautiful
it gets to be a monument to what was and
a nod to the future and we're going to
rebuild something completely different
so when i look at somebody like this
like taylor who has had to be on their
own because for whatever reason her
husband was in jail for three years
there is no going back
there's taylor's world now right and
taylor has sounds like she's found a new
voice she's found some actions that back
up that voice and she's
found two feet planted in the ground and
what i want taylor to do is to
immediately go sit with a counselor
that's going to help with reentry here
how are you going to
learn how to speak your boundaries out
loud how are you going to say
i'm sorry but this is like we're going
to do this together now you're not just
going to come home and start making up
the rules that got you in trouble in the
first place right
and it's about we're going to excavate
what was we used to run the house this
way you used to do some things this way
we're now going to do things different
or and then you've got to have your what
statement right and so if somebody comes
home out of jail and immediately throws
my family back into a situation we're
not safe we're gonna have some hard
conversations right um yeah that i just
kept thinking taylor's a different
person now that's right she was three
she started the plan after he went to
jail right and now here she is a
different person with a different set of
plans and values and goals and different
financial standing and different
strengths yeah right different grit and
resilience and autonomy those these
these deeply embedded character things
her body went from fight or flight to
we're moving forward right and that's a
different that's a different physiology
i just kept thinking taylor's better off
alone than she is with him that was my
honest thought if you want to know john
well when it comes to money possibly and
it sounds like um i i i we you know we
always read into these things um it
sounds like she
is hesitant about him coming home yeah
and so man i want you to get with
somebody that's going to help turn these
boundaries these newfound
actions this newfound character newfound
strength it's going to be able to turn
that into something that you can share
with somebody and that you can stand up
and say no no no this is my boundaries
from this point forward yeah counseling
is a non-negotiable here for sure